[Music]
so what's up guys we will revisit
dragons of bur and we will showcase the
10 biggest title CLA dragons from that
show from the movies the How to Train
Your Dragon movies and the later
Animated Series so let's get to it at
number 10 we have the flut Fang the
flood Fang is a title class dragon and
Dragons the nine Realms resembling a
large aquatic manay with two long wings
and no legs it features a tall dorsal
fin with spines and a fish-like tail the
eyes are high on the skull but its gills
are present down there in the neck
capable of both underwater and aerial
existence the flood Fang can leave water
bodies without drying out with the
ability to store water it can launch
itself from water bodies using Jaws
lined with full of sharp teeth and Tusk
to catch prey or unsuspecting victims
high up in the air number nine the
octoin the octopan a massive title class
dragon from Dragon against the nine
Realms resembles a crocodile with a snot
full of protruding teeth and striking
red eyes it features multiple Dorsal
fins three pairs on its head and eight
tails which look like octopus tentacles
the octopan akin to octopi and Squids
can emit an ink for camouflage and
defense demonstrating remarkable
strength one individual showcase
Endurance by withstanding attacks from
its natural adversary the shell fire but
despite its mysterious Behavior it seems
to have a gentle nature
number eight the scal Dron the scal
draon a large title class Dragon seen in
the How to Train Your Dragon movies is
akin to Giant stations in size with four
stubby legs it is a massive sea dragon
that generates heat to warm the water it
inhales inside the scald drron has a
long thin neck and a slender head
featuring a bottom jaw pouch which makes
it look funny although primarily a
non-fire breather it can produce water
at extreme heat capable of peeling in
the scales of of a screaming death and
since they are water breeders they can
even take down the notorious krills as
well number seven the fathom fin the
fathom fin a colossal title class Dragon
introduced in the Serpent's air is
described by Richard Hamilton as a
leviathan class Dragon synonymous with a
tile class Titan Wing this enormous
Dragon features a predominantly blue hue
or color Ador with dark green spots a
sizable fin along its back and Barnacles
reminiscent of those found on real Bine
whales limited information is available
about this Dragon but it is stated to be
a peaceful one number six the subar
riper the subar riper a massive title
and tracker class dragon from the
dragons series got race to the edge is
characterized by its enormous size teeth
comparable to Vikings in size and a
distinctive head to body ratio with a
rounded head and snout it features lops
Nubs and Stripes along its body which
makes it look distinct as well as having
frog-like legs with wept feet and short
Wings notable for its ability to
generate whps by sucking in nearby water
the subar riper is a powerful Dragon
powerful enough to engulf large ships or
dragons like scarron in its Whirlpool
very formidable it even faced and
tackled a Titan Wing shell fire number
five the SE gronkle the SE gronkle
introduced in dragons rescue Riders is a
sizable and large Dragon resembling a
whale it possesses a body a flat snout
with prominent nostrils and a dorsal fin
similar to those seen on dolphins or
shars additionally these dragons have
large nostrils on their heads directly
linked to their mouths eating and
swimming despite their large size
despite their large size the sea grones
have notably small eyes slightly larger
than those of a human these sea grunkles
can use their large nostrils to send BLS
of water above them or right in front of
them as a defense mechanism
number four the shell fire the shell
fire a massive title class dragon from
Dragon's race to the edge is initially
smaller than an octopan or even a submar
riper in its normal adult form but as a
Titan wing it stands as one of the
series largest dragons featuring long
curved horns a smaller nose horn a
devilish extended Wings which are
seemingly unfit for flight and it has a
rugged dorsal protective shell capable
of shooting plasma charged Boulders
these project Iles have a range of over
a mile and can deal serious
damage number three the Luminous grain
so the Luminous crin is a massive title
class dragon from the school of dragon
series resembling gentle Turtles with an
armored backshell and elongated flippers
their growth stages comparable to frogs
result in physical changes to adapt to
different environments hatchlings can
even live on land and fly but as they
mature their wings elongate for an
entirely aquatic environment according
to Bo's papers to become a Clon
Leviathan or a Titan Wing such a crin
must consume a dragon bloom plant and if
it does it will grow to be one of the
largest dragons ever number two the
purple death the purple death a gigantic
title class Dragon introduced in the
Legends of Ragnarok is a massive
creature causing seaquakes due to its
immense size Viking Legends identify it
as the serpent of midot heralding
Ragnarok the end of times it is believed
to be bigger than the green and even the
red Deads notable features include long
tendrils resembling a beard and a
snake-like body with deep purple
coral-like plates and an absence of
wings suggesting it may be unable to fly
due to its size and weight but it does
breathe highly explosive Fire In Waves
capable of devastating entire Villages
of fleets just like the Red Death and
number one the bewilder beast a colossal
title class dragon from from How to
Train Your Dragon too it is a massive
four-legged dragon with gigantic Tusk
resembling those of elephant tusk and
also elephant likee legs it has a flat
almost hum shaped face with a white
mouth it also has flexible lips and two
large eyes of varying colors it
possesses short antenna likee spikes
between the eyes that can vibrate
rapidly and a flaring crown of spikes
extending from the back of the head the
adult bewilder bees has fin-like wings
on its side used for swimming instead of
flying and the one scene in the movie is
520 ft long while its Titan Wing is
noted to be almost 650 ft long so if you
like this video then check this other
one out and if you're more interested in
other movie monsters and creatures then
check out our Channel as well we might
just have things that you haven't seen
or even thought about subscribe like and
we'll see you on the next video take
care fam